out of control Britney's dad makes a
bold move against the free Brittany
movement really the concern for Brittany
has been building there's her Instagram
posts the fight about her
conservatorship the question is what is
really going on
yeah well this we know Jamie is their
conservator and he has had enough
et has obtained a copy of the lawsuit
filed by Brittany's dad which says quote
it's time for conspiracy theories about
Britney Spears well-being and the mob
hashtag free Britney movement to stop
the soup focuses on the fansite Absolut
Britney which claimed that Britney's
team deleted positive comments on
Instagram to make the singer appear
troubled and in need of help a source
tells us Britney's team has received
death threats and law enforcement
recently got involved we reached out to
29 year old Anthony Aaliyah who helps
run Absolut Britney he told us quote I
am forever blessed and I have faith that
good always wins and no further comments
except that I love Britney and the
Britney army the lawsuit that was filed
by Jamie yesterday was unusual you know
I'll be honest with you attorney
tomorrow our manic represents Amanda
Bynes conservators she is not involved
in Britney's case but believes Jamie's
defamation case is a long shot Britney
is a public figure and so it's kind of
open season I don't think this fan is
going to have a very hard time finding
lawyers and attorneys that are willing
to take it all the way
[Music]
still what about Brittany's Instagram is
it hurting her brand and should her fans
be worried guys okay I just got home
guess what the housekeeper's just into
my closet amidst the workouts and bikini
pictures are some puzzling post
yesterday Brittany instagrammed an image
of Mary Magdalene calling her the most
interesting person in the Bible and she
posted the view from her bathtub and
there was that paparazzi conspiracy
theory is the news really real it's a
conspiracy theory that I'm actually
interested in I don't think we should be
worried I think it's just indicative of
the conservator her father giving her
access to her social media now it's just
Brittany and her phone putting up
whatever she wants to put up
while the next court hearing for
Brittany's conservatorship is August the
15th she is not required to appear but
she can if she wants to
[Applause]
[Music]